I have a very very special Black Friday
deal for you and that is a hugely
discounted offer on stylecraft now if
you don't know what stockcraft is it is
a mentorship and training program for
visual creators motion designers looking
to dramatically upgrade your motion
design skills and build confidence in
your abilities stylecraft consists of
over 80 lessons 40 project files and 30
hours of training this program is a
monster and for Black Friday I am
offering it forget this 297 dollars or
two payments of 147. I have never
offered this course at this low of a
price point but I want to make it as
accessible to as many people as possible
so if you've been eyeing it this is your
chance how do you get this special price
you go to motionscience.tv on November
25th Black Friday and you get it then